The Battle of Olympus.
This is an ancient story.
A time when men and gods live together.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean. And I'm Joe.
The Battle of Olympus.
Many comparisons have been offered, even on our own Patreon feed, to Zelda 2 The Adventure of Link.
I guess I could see it.
The player is a hero, sword and a shield.
It's a side-scrolling adventure game.
You're traveling from town to town.
You have to rescue a princess.
I guess that's up for debate, you know, like, where she stands on, like, Zelda's hierarchy of princesses.
But, nevertheless, you have to rescue her.
And, believe it or not, a final confrontation with a shadow.
Just like in Zelda 2.
So, I guess there's a lot of similarities here in this game.
Did you guys pick up on that pretty quickly?
Yeah, I'd even say that it goes even further.
Like, the actual, like, yes, it's a side-scroller.
But it also just, like, really feels like Zelda 2.
Down to just, like, the moment-to-moment.
Like, oh, that jump feels like the jump from Zelda 2.
That kind of stuff. Yeah, it's that, like, platform-y combat side-scrolling that, like, that Zelda 2 sort of made popular, I guess.
You know, or Faxanadu being the other example that we recently played.
Yeah, and I think with Faxanadu, the difference was the exploration of the map was all, you were always on the same map.
And you had to kind of scroll across and stuff like that.
Whereas, you know, to a lesser extent, Battle of Olympus, but definitely Zelda 2.
They have this larger map where you travel between areas.
And in Zelda 2, it's an actual overworld that you walk into the towns on the overhead map.
In the Battle of Olympus, it's more like you're zoomed out for a second and you get to see where you are in Greece.
And then you're brought back in to the same location.
Yeah, I mean, it could have also totally worked without that if they had just, like, if they just told you where you were.
But it seems like they wanted to have that map of Greece.
So I feel like in that sense, it is a little closer to Faxanadu than it is to Legend of Zelda.
Where, like, Legend of Zelda, the overworld plays such a big part.
So the Battle of Olympus poses itself as a very, you know, big adventure on the NES.
Similar to other larger RPGs that we've played.
Given the Greek setting and the fact that I recently read the Odyssey, I feel like it's good to start there and just think of, you know, the one of the most epic tales.
One of the first stories ever told, I guess, in the grand scheme of literature.
Is this, you know, meeting that grandness of Greek literature in the compelling story?
Let's just start with plot points, not actual gameplay grandness.
I mean, no, but hold on.
You just recently, on your own accord, like, read the entirety of the Odyssey?
I went to Greece, so I thought it was, like, appropriate reading.
Oh, yeah. That was, like, the first travel blog for Greece.
Yeah, yeah. The Odyssey really rubble.
Like, where to go?
Did you eat any lotus?
Did you take any hallucinogenics?
I'll tell you one thing, though.
I wasn't, when I went on my ferry to get from one island to another, I didn't wind up hearing a siren song and being called to it for ten years, thanks to the book.
That's true. That's probably for the best.
Yeah. I think about it.
I could have been away from the podcast for ten years if I didn't read the Odyssey.
So, okay.
In terms of the plot of the Battle of Olympus, you play Orpheus, or I guess like a child version of Orpheus, and you're looking for, you know, the classical, mythological love interest of Orpheus, Helen.
Which is not, not really.
It's Eurydice, but it's Helen in this game, and basically you, I guess Aphrodite really likes that you're in love with Helen, and she, like, recruits all of her god friends to help you get to her.
And, uh, that's what you do.
You sort of, like, knock on, like, you go door to door knocking on the gods' temples and asking for gifts to get to Helen, and you do that.
Do we know if, like, we're playing, like, if they just picked Orpheus because it was a name from Greek mythology?
Are we playing as, like, the kid?
Are we playing as Orpheus from Greek mythology?
Because I did not think we were actually him, because he's a child, first of all.
Yeah, he doesn't seem to have any musical talents.
I mean, he has a harp, eventually, and an ocarina.
But he doesn't seem to, like, come from that background.
He just, like, you know, he had to, like, you know, in order to impress a girl in high school, you might take up guitar and not have that be, like, your defining characteristic.
This seems like a half-baked version of Orpheus.
Or in order to summon a pegasus to take you to a town over, you take up Ocarina.
Yeah, the flute.
You know, noted example of never use this in a school essay.
Wikipedia says that Orpheus is the same Orpheus from Greek mythology.
So do with that information what you will.
Yeah, it's just wrong.
It's just wrong. Right. I also, like, you know, it's not even, nothing in the game implies that other than the harp, I suppose.
But what I mean is, is, like, they just attached the reference to the other article on Orpheus inside the plot description of the Battle of Olympus.
I don't think there's any, like, definitive evidence that links the two together.
Well, I mean, everything else does.
Why else? I'm saying that the developer of the game wanted it to be Orpheus, but it does not matter because you get to name yourself and your girlfriend.
So, you know, you can name him Link.
Sean, that's a great point.
This is one of the first games where you can name your girlfriend.
That's true. Usually you only ever get to name, like, the hero character.
But this, yeah, you get to name your girlfriend.
I mean, I don't even know the first time you, because I, I couldn't get that far in this game.
So I never saw my girlfriend's name written out on the screen.
But it's funny that they let you do it with how infrequent you'll see it.
But you know what? You can't name your character.
Orpheus. It doesn't fit.
So I always named my character my name because I'm boring.
But is that, does that mean that, like, if you just don't fill it out, then it defaults to Orpheus?
You know, I didn't try.
Right. How do we ever find out that this, other than the manual at the back of the box, like, how do we ever find out?
It couldn't be spelled if it does do it that way.
It couldn't be spelled the way it's spelled in the manual because there's not enough character space.
Yeah. I don't know.
Maybe you're like Orphex or like RFx.
That doesn't work.
So, Sean, you're beating up the plot a little bit.
But now if we could introduce some of the gameplay and let's just talk about exploration here.
Being able to travel between multiple, you know, real Greek locations.
And yes, it's just a brief look at the overworld map before you're then brought back into the side schooling portion.
Being able to travel between, you know, Athens and all the way down to Crete.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah. Like that adds to the scale of like, you know, modern Greek mythology of how it seemed like even all that time ago, those guys just got around.
You know, transportation was not an issue for these guys.
No, I mean, it seems like you could just go on like a midday stroll and accidentally end up in Peloponnesus.
It's strange. Well, you just walk into the wrong door.
And then you walk out the other door and now you're in another city.
Yeah.
Like how long was the segue between these areas that I've jumped over to entirely different cities?
Well, what I took it as maybe I'm maybe I'm just giving them like throwing them a bone here is like that.
That what the gameplay is like the stuff where the action is happening.
And then when you get to the map, it's like, OK, and then you travel the rest of the way, but nothing.
Yeah, I guess you can use that part of the world.
That's sort of D&D ask like and then you went the rest of the way.
Yeah, I'll buy that.
But is it exciting to progress?
Because, you know, it's one thing to say like, oh, you get to go, you know, fight a lot of different enemies and you get to see a lot of different things.
But is the is the adventure scaling proportionally or are you just kind of doing the same thing in new regions?
I think what makes it feel like it is more than just doing the same thing in new regions is that there's a good amount of of items and elements that you run into that kind of lean that kind of guide you towards growth.
So like you'll get better weapons.
You get a weapon with a projectile.
You get what is it?
You get Hermes's sandals, which sounds lame, but it lets you like walk on treetops.
And jump higher, which lets you get to do.
I mean, you know, that's just classic like Metroidvania stuff.
But even like the little power ups and stuff are sort of something that's like driving you throughout.
At least I felt.
And then, you know, we touched on like the story is not.
Yeah, it's no Odyssey in any way.
But like, I don't know how this translated to kids in 1989.
But if you're interested in Greek mythology, it's kind of cool to be like, oh, next I'm going to go to.
You know, to find Athena.
And then, oh, what's Ares going to have for me?
It's like, you know, like, you know that they'll have something that might fit what you know about those about those gods.
So like that's another thing that sort of like makes that propels me forward a little bit.
It's like what's going to be next in this Greek mythology that I'm already aware of.
Yeah, there's enough like there's enough actual mythology or at least like the background of a mythology like that.
Like if this was your first exposure to it and then you started learning it in social studies or whatever the fuck you might learn about mythology.
And you'd be like, oh, yeah, I remember like Prometheus gave me my my fire wand or made my wand go fire.
So that makes sense.
So that's pretty cool in terms of the scale, though.
And meeting all these guys and I do I do think that this game feels big for how.
So, however, it's actually set up, which is more so like a big like interconnected maze.
Yeah. And I would just say, too, they've included some nice touches of gameplay and story like mixing together things that don't necessarily matter, but are elements of just cool style in terms of storytelling.
I think about every time you want to speak to the gods in normal characters, you just walk up to the characters and you press the B button, which is usually your attack button and can make some awkward looking screens where it looks like you're obviously you can never stab the NPCs, but it looks like you're stabbing them.
And that's not nice. So I don't know why they would map the talk button to the stab button, but that can't happen with the gods.
They're actually on the altar and you can't like jump up over to them.
So you try just pressing the talk button and that doesn't work either.
You figure out that you have to actually kneel before them to engage them in conversation.
And I feel like that is a fun mix of, you know, gameplay and storytelling coming together that we don't usually see.
No, that was funny.
It's immersion. It was also pretty funny when I thought I got to Zeus or some, you know, it kind of looks like Jesus, but I thought I got to Zeus and immediately is just saying, like, who are you?
Get out of here. What are you doing here?
And then I didn't know what to do.
And I realized that I would like, you know, I, I didn't go to the first place somehow.
But that was a cool little bit of like environmental storytelling where you just didn't talk to the right guy first.
And now no one likes you.
Yeah. Cause it's, I did the same thing.
because what it is is you're supposed to
your first task is to go talk to Zeus
which they do, someone does tell you
so I give them
a pass for that, it is like
a little bit of
a missable thing where you're like
what am I supposed to do first?
You don't know if that's Zeus or not Zeus
it looks like Zeus
That's true, I mean I'm sure we'll talk about that
too, there's a lot of hints
or advice that's given to you that you don't really
know how to interpret it because you don't know
the rest of the information
you need, it'll say like
go do this, but you're like what's that?
where is that? One guy says I know the
whatever MacGuffin thing he's talking
about is that way
he doesn't point or anything, he just says it's that way
like it's in that direction
and I'm like okay, I don't know what you're talking about
but I did the same thing where
I didn't talk to Zeus first
I went to the town and
nobody was going to
help me because you're supposed to go
and kind of like get the task from the gods
and then once you go back it's like
I mean the, I guess the
idea is like oh my god
like Zeus sent you?
Like yeah, whatever you need
you know, it's like that's cool
but it's also a little missable
yeah, I think that that stuff works nicely
into the next thing I wanted to talk about
which is that there is an element
of non-linear gameplay here
even in the sense of
you know, we were saying Metroidvania
but a lot of times that
kind of thing is like
oh, you get a new item that allows you to
explore a previously
explored area but with
in a new way that you'll unlock new things
I don't think this game quite has that
but instead what it has going for it
is it'll tell you like
hey, you're probably not like
strong enough for this area
I'd advise you to stay out
but it doesn't stop you
from entering
there's a few items
that are like gatekeeping you
from like hidden cave entrances
and stuff like that
but for the most part like
say you don't go talk to Zeus right away
I think you can even get all the way down
to like Athens
without ever like speaking to any NPC
and the game doesn't say like
you know, you're going like
really far away
from where you need to be right now
you know, it doesn't hold your hand
in that kind of way but that's not really that far
it's like not much progress
it's far like as the crow flies
but just going to Athens
doesn't mean you've made progress
in the actual game
yeah, but theoretically
you could already do like
some side quests
and pick up like that
the staff, right?
Is that what you get? The staff of fennel?
Yeah, that
from that woman yeah, like
you could get some of that stuff
I'd say that's almost like soft locked
behind the shield
because of the enemy guarding
the trigger
Yes, and that's why I said theoretically
theoretically, you know
but I'm saying like the game doesn't like
lock this content
behind particular items
being unlocked
or, you know they're just triggered
by you going to those areas
and those areas
aren't gatekept by items
so I feel like I don't know
I thought that was a nice touch
that you can
you can
you can explore and do wrong
in this game
Yeah It's not confusing though
I guess you know it's not
for me I never felt like
I don't know where the hell I am
or what I'm supposed to do
I don't agree with that
but I'm sure we'll get there
and I guess I'm not being
entirely like truthful there too
because with a game of this scale
I played with a guide
so Okay
that's why I could understand
yeah I could understand
that if you're
yeah if you're not playing
with a guide or at least
with some kind of map
it is a little tricky
to figure out especially given that
entrances to
new areas
are also the same
as entrances
to like people's houses
and such
it's not it's not really well communicated
when you're moving on
because sometimes when you move on
you're just
progressing to the next section
of the same area
in another screen
by just going to the right
and then you kind of
hit these dead ends
dead ends
don't necessarily
lead to doors
that will take you
to the next area you might have missed
that door a while back
and just not known about it
yeah
the navigation
in this game
is also one of the reasons
why I wouldn't call it
a Metroidvania
not so much
even like the
gatekeeping item
portion of it
it's because the way that
a Metroidvania
sets up its stuff
it it's
a lot easier
to
get a lay of the land
and you'll
because it's all in the same plane
like it's
all over
2D space
but you don't ever
go into a door
that puts you in another layer
of the game that it's gonna
like wormhole back
into the
primary layer
in some other
weird portal
it's just all there
and
one of my main problems
with playing this
game was just I
did not have a sense
of direction and yeah
I know I could have used a
walkthrough just to
have like oh
walk through the second
weird door
to your right
and then it's just more so
like following instructions
than actually like
knowing where
you are and I
I just couldn't get beyond
that in some
senses yeah
I was like torn
because at first
when I first played it
or when I first started I was
like wow compared to
you know compared to
Zelda 2 and
Faxanadu
the
the like
information you
get from NPCs
is even better
is like has really
like makes me feel
like oh maybe I don't
need a guide for this game
because they are really
telling me a lot of things
like they're telling me a lot
of information that like you
know maybe this really does
like kind of
feel more like a like an RPG
that I'm more
used to have a more
modern type of game where it's
like oh I can do this without
a guide because it's all there
in the game but like I said
a lot of that information is not
like complete
or like doesn't
actually guide you
to what to do next it says
like this is what you need to get
next and I'm like
okay well I have no idea where
that is like
and yes you can just explore until
you find it but that's that feels
like it does sometimes miss the
purpose of having those NPCs telling
you what to do next because if
you tell me this is what I need
next that's the
same as me not knowing what I
need next if I
don't know where like have a hint
as to where I
need to go like
if you just say you need this
thing and it's
like just explore until you find
it if you didn't
tell me that I
would have just explored until I
found the next thing so like that
that element of it
like kind of
made me like of
two minds like at
first I was like they did a lot
well about making
this feel like you're
not like aimless but
then there are like I
also used a guide and
there were like a lot of parts in the guide
where it was like
okay go through the
first door after this
and then go through the third door after
that and then two
doors to the right of that one and then
one door to the
right of this and
I'm like maybe there
was some way I could have solved that with
the information in the
game that wasn't just
guess and check but
like so like if I
if I play this game
a lot more and I find out like oh
wait I was just missing things then
I'll take this back but I don't think
that is the case I
think that that it's
just another one of those games that you
really need a guide
which isn't hasn't
been necessarily the
kiss of death for
other games that I've
needed a guide that I still really loved but
it was not a point in
its favor Joe you're talking
about the NPC
dialogue on a lot of
on a lot of like you
know they tell you to
go to this thing
right usually with
NPCs in these kinds
of games both in
Simon's Quest and in
in Zelda 2 in some
regards we've been
upset with the
localization and just
the truth of what
they're saying and
and the validity of
the statements they're making you know this
isn't this that's what
we usually complain about it's not
necessarily the case
here but I think
that you know this
is a very boring
example of like what
could happen if if it
was all correct anyway because it
winds up being something where even
if you could understand you know
with with hindsight
like having maybe right it would just
be vague it's just go go or do X and
you will get Y and
you know seeing it
now with with a game
that actually got it all right it seems
like wow it actually
isn't a very interesting
mechanic and obviously
modern NPCs have
figured this out a lot better but for a game
that's setting itself
up to be this grand
story I feel like they
could have added more color to these NPCs
than just flat out
saying go to X and
get Y yeah like one
example of it was
still very simple
dialogue but at least
felt like you were
having an impact on
this world and it wasn't just a bunch of
trivia knowledge keepers
that were in all of
these towns was when
you know you you
you're actually kind
of just it's not
really a side quest
because you you do
need the staff but
when you go through
the town that's next
to Athens that I
don't remember the name of you're talking
to this woman it's
like oh my my child
has been kidnapped
by a witch or a
harpy or whatever she
is and then the father
is like hey my
daughter lost her
kid can you go find
it then you go and
you fight this like
mini boss and then
you go into the cave
and you find the kid
and then you bring
word back that you
found the kid it
might still be playing
in the in the cave for
some reason you don't
see him leave but
then you talk to the
mother and she's like
oh thank you here's the
thing my dad knows
more about the thing
you should talk to him and then you go
and talk to him and
he's like oh prometheus he's got
the you know he
knows how to use this thing I I
liked that it felt
like you know
conversations more so
than you know this
guy Hephaestus makes
really great swords
just wanted to let
you know that yeah
it felt like you exist in this world
yeah right the
follow-up is good on
those things too the
fact that the NPC
first leads you to a
boss fight if you
will and then you
complete the boss fight and then that
same NPC then leads
you to the next thing
like that feels a lot
better than when you
first what town are you
in when you first start the game
Arcadia yes okay yeah
when you're in Arcadia there's a bunch
of NPCs that you could
talk to but unless
you're like have a
notepad out and are
writing these things
down you're gonna
have to go like check back in with
them at some point
for what they what
kind of clues they gave you because it's
not stuff that's
immediately happening
and there is no oh
go follow back up with
my brother in Arcadia
he lives in the first
house to the left like
that would be stupid but like you know how
else would they tell you I guess you know
there's not a lot of that in this game
yeah it was just a
very memorable example
of the few times it
does that many
locations in this
game but I feel like
it suffers a little
from that Simon's
quest problem where
you have to walk
between every location
so if you ever you
know in a game that tells you like first
you go here and
then you go there and then you go back
there there is a lot
of backtracking in this game a little more
than even for Xanadu
had but this game is
large so if you want
to for whatever reason
go all the way back to
Arcadia at some point
it's a lot of
backtracking and
walking through and
dealing with you know
enemies are always
kind of just a nuisance
at any level uh you
know the nicer your
sword is does it mean
that the kind of bats
that fly around or um
that even those blue
slimes that you start
off with in the game like those things are
still going to be
something that you're gonna have to either
dodge to make sure that
you don't die from my point just being
that Zelda 2's world
map uh solved all of
this by just making
like the overworld
something that's very quick to move between
town to town and then
like the dungeons and
towns are really big
once you get inside of
them it feels weird in
in um in Battle of
Olympus where if you're
three towns away from
where you need to be it's like guess I just
gotta go all the way
back the way I already
came uh even though I
don't think I'm gonna discover anything new
and that could have
been solved with some
metrovania like elements
but as Sean's already discussed that doesn't
quite happen in this
game yeah on paper I
I think that I like I
agree with that like
that that when you say
it I'm like yeah that
that's poorly designed
but something about these
games I mean because fix and a dude did sort
of a similar thing like
you said and I feel
like sometimes the right
amount of backtracking if
it's not if it's not too
much like doesn't hurt
with like the immersiveness
and like I guess the
fact that this game doesn't feel quite so
like it feels big because
there's all these different locations and
stuff but really when you
think about it it's not
each location is not that
big and it never felt to
me like a slog to have
to go through it it felt
like I was getting familiar with the world
and I it kind of felt
cool to me after a little
while when it's like when
I was like oh I gotta you
know go back to Attica like I know how to get
there from here I
remember this here's our
little journey you know that's kind of maybe made
the like farming that I
needed to do later for
money a little more tolerable because I was
already doing it while
I'm like traveling and
then also the fact that
I'd say less than halfway
through the game I'm
guessing I can't remember
but like you get this fast travel option which
is not a perfect fast
travel option as far as
player convenience but it
makes it um
it usually seems to be
designed in a way where
like it'll take you to
where you probably want to
go next wait can you
describe this because I
don't think I got there
yeah so what it is is you
get uh the harp and if you
go to I'm trying to remember
what they are it's like these statues that are in
each area if you go to it
and play the harp the
pegasus will come down and
take you to another town
but you don't choose the
town each one has like a
fixed place you go to from
that town okay so it's
like kind of weird but
like if you're in what
like what is it peloponnesus that was
called yep uh you you
know I think it takes you
back to arcadia so each
town like wherever the
pegasus is like it it
will only bring you to one
other town it's not like
a yeah like from there
it'll only ever take you
to arcadia but then like
from arcadia I you know
I actually didn't test if
it just will take you back
to peloponnesus I think it
takes you somewhere else
but I think it's designed
where it's probably where
you want to go next okay
because so because I never
had a problem with like
oh shit how do I get
there it was always like oh perfect it's exactly
where I want to go but it
feels like also if you
really wanted to get I
mean maybe it's just a
little bit of a tedious
prototype for a fast travel
system but it feels like if
I really wanted to get to
one I could just fly to one
this isn't where I want to go fly again this isn't
where I want to go fly again okay here I am so
like kind of uncool but but
but it still feels like a
reward because it takes a
it takes away the like
weight of having to long
travel everywhere it feels
like progress yeah maybe a
little clumsy in execution
but definitely better than
I don't think Simon's
Quest ever offered anything in the idea of
fast travel so I you know
could be better but we'll
take it and you're right
actually the harp of Apollo
I wouldn't even say like
mid game I think you I think
you get that fairly early
fairly early on not like
right away well I didn't get
it I'd say a third of the
game there you go third of the
game in everybody knows where
the third of the game mark is
it says it on the screen
right it says you've now made
it one third of the way
through once you collect the
harp actually like after the
like just after the Hydra boy
I mean I got I guess it's a
yeah it's a yeah the Hydra boy
yeah I think it is actually
the next thing after the
Hydra boy right wow whoops
it could be or somewhere
close to there let's talk about the items in
the game and not just the
harp and the ocarina and
stuff like that but also your
weaponry because that upgrades
you know it's not just you're
you got from club to sword
and and your strength went
up like plus one there there
are like some cool items that
you can either you know miss or
collect or or you know they
they give you like a new
ability I think in terms of you
know comparing it to Zelda again
I feel like there was some
exciting items in this game that
kept me on my toes in terms of
like what I was about to
receive yeah definitely I mean
there are the ones that we
talked about that are like sort
of just making it so you've
unlocked things like there's the
the one that's like the the the
eye that lets you see hidden
doors like that one is just like
okay this is just for here for
progress but a bunch of them are
like yeah they feel like tools
that can be used in different
ways even like you said the
weapons you get the club and you
get the sword like yeah that
that's just a strength boost but
then there's like the staff that
does the same thing as the sword
but then you also have a
projectile you can shoot out of
it like it's not just like they
they made there's some intention
to each like upgrade to your items
as well this is what I've been
asking for for like since we
started this podcast was like a
like when your upgrades aren't just
a like a step up in terms of
damage scale or just another way to
make something a key like it's
actually you can use this in
different ways like Apollo you know
you can jump higher and that I got
it I thought that's all it did but
then you can stand on the ceiling and
I was just like oh that's cool I
didn't think that would have like a
secondary effect and it's the same
with the staffs like okay yeah it's a
little bit more damage at first and
then you finally talk to Prometheus
and it gives you the projectile so I
really like the way they did the
upgrades in this game yeah and again
that's another great story element to
of like you don't just get the staff
and it shoots fire you have to speak
to Prometheus in order to theoretically
have been trained to learn how to do
that thing some people might say
that's tedious I don't know I think
in this kind of game where they're
trying to talk about like you know a
hero on his journey learning how to
take down Hades like that's pretty
cool that they took that extra step
there because you're right like the
staff by itself is more powerful than
the club so it's already got like some
kind of boost to it interestingly
enough they also put some trade-offs at
least in the staff where the you know
those salamanders are fire resistant so
when you're down in the salamander cave
you can't just shoot flames at them to
deal with them you have to hit them
still with the staff is fine but you
have to hit them you can't just spam
fire at them and collect olives
non-stop from them yeah
but to that point you don't feel like
okay I've got the next step up in
weapons so I'll never go back to the
other weapon there are reasons to
switch I think that the sword actually
has better I could be wrong as better
attack power than the staff if you're
just hitting things that is true like
that so that would make it like
beneficial like okay I'm gonna fight a
bunch of salamanders I'm gonna switch
to the sword and then eventually you get
that the whatever the super powerful
sword is after the staff the master
the divine sword yeah the master sword
and then you get the divine sword and
that has that's more powerful than the
staff and has a projectile but the
projectile drains like one half point
of your health every time you use it
so it's like it's better but like you
might want to switch like I found
myself switching back to the staff
sometimes too like it was never like
okay well that's worthless now because
I got the next thing it was always
there was always decisions to be made
as to like except for the club you
never go back to the club well that
feels like a good segue into the battle
system which is a whole other part of
this game so far we have been focusing
just on the exploration and story
elements of this game but it now feels
like a good time to talk about the
battle system since we've talked about
some of the items you'll unlock you
know I think we I think we talked about
like in Zelda 2 it's really cool how
fight scenes are brought down like
duels on the overworld like you just
you run into an enemy and then it just
brings you into a screen and it's
almost like a sword fighting matchup a
1v1 where you're trying to take
control of the screen this is more like
fazanadu in that regard where enemies
are always just on the side schooling
part of it and you only ever fight them
that way I'll just start with the very
beginning of the game to see why I don't
really like this kind of combat it's not
my preferred way it's not like it's not
the worst thing in the world but those
blue slimes that you can only attack when
they jump but they fall from the ceiling
and you know that's just be mindful or
whatever but then they continue to move
towards you constantly at this like
sluggish sluggish pace and you can try to
crouch but you still can't hit them and
keep in mind is the very first enemy in
the game so you have to be properly
positioned for when they jump since you
need to be standing in the correct spot
at the same time I suppose you could just
keep your distance and try to lunge forward
at them with a sword jump to time when
when they jump in the air and yeah these
guys don't do a ton of damage and it's not
the end of the world or anything but for
this to be the first experience with the
battle system it showed me the limitations
of you know like of this kind of fighting
that like that it does take some precision
striking and that the enemies are more
powerful and in some regards less
vulnerable than the player yeah I that the
anything that's too short is incredibly
frustrating and you don't have to be
standing in a specific spot to hit those
little slimes like if you just crouch and
just spam the sword while it approaches you
it will eventually jump into your sword but
regardless the the kind of philosophy that
seems to have gone into enemy placement in
this game is sort of all over the place
like in some places the enemies seem to be
very specifically placed that you like have
to like bait them out and like jump over on
the or bait them out and fight them normally
or like it's it's intentional and then
there's times where it just feels like
let's just cram them as much stuff as we can on
the screen and well they'll they'll get hit
like three times in a row and eventually
fall down a hole that's sort of how it felt
like there wasn't any it didn't feel across
the board like they were trying to do the
same thing I had sort of like an interesting
relationship with the battle system here
because to start I really liked it yes the the
slime thing kind of kind of weird that you that
the first enemy is too low to the ground for
you to hit I think there is only one other
enemy that does that though towards the end is
the caterpillar as far as I can remember so
like that's definitely weird like especially
that's the first enemy I never felt like they
were like cramming too much on the screen
ever like I always felt like it was it always
felt pretty intentional yeah there were some that
would like respawn when you kill them like we've
seen in some other games but it was never to
that like really annoying like karate kid level
where it really bothered me that much but the
thing is when I first started I really liked it
and there was something about it that I was
like this feels better than I was used to from
what I remember it's been a while but from
Zelda 2 or Vaxanadu and I couldn't put my finger
on what it was about it was like oh like this
combat feels really good and it feels really like
responsive and whatnot as the game went on I could
not put my finger on it like I was just getting
really bored of the combat like it was hard and
sometimes and whatnot but like by the end I was
like something about it was just like not holding my
attention and I think what I realized was that what I
had mistaken for like really good one-to-one input
recognition really also kind of amounted to like just
there's no cool down to your attack so like Sean like
you said if you just you rapid fire that button above
the slime and it'll jump into your sword as long as
you're hitting it quickly enough there are some
enemies where like it would jump at me like those monkeys
later on that are really annoying it would jump at me and
it would feel like I can hit him a bunch of time and that
hit me but then I realized oh if I hit faster if I really go
rapid fire I can hit it an extra time and kill it which makes
it eventually feel like yeah the fact that like Zelda 2 has
that cooldown which makes it a little more challenging and just
makes it a little more like I have to think a little more even
if it's like a fraction like my brain is working a little more
to make it like a challenge rather than just hey just spam a as
fast as I can I'm making it sound really negative but it was
like that was what made me realize like why I got like a
little more tired of this combat more quickly than I did for
Zelda or Zelda 2 or FX Anadu and you you kind of have to spam
sometimes given uh where you are in in the caves or uh specific
locations in the overworld because enemies do just continue to
spawn and you know approach you pretty quickly so you kind of
have to take a back seat to progress and either you know try to
jump around them and just forget them all together or stand there
stab stab stab move a little bit another enemy spawns in a scorpion
or something and then get rid of them keep moving just a little bit
like inching your way it's almost like a game of football where
you're just kind of you know nothing's really like intimidating
you that much but you're just inching closer to the end zone
across plays uh that's that's kind of how I had the experience
with these normal enemies in the game just the ones that you'll
see over and over and over again the the boss fights which we'll get
into in a minute much more creative but these enemies just back to my point
that I guess I was trying to make with the the first enemies too is just
that they feel like they're coming at you a lot quicker in a larger number
and also with you know a lot of different types that your hero adventure
thing like the the idea of you being someone who's going to take down Hades
right the the little guys ruin that and then the bosses make you feel like big
and cool again yeah I mean again it's it it's also I think a part of the like the
patterns that these enemies with enough of them on the screen do like they're either
just jumping maniacally around or they're uh they're they're just moving towards you
uh at a constant rate and at maybe just like moving at random too it it's really hard to
anticipate like there's no tells it it doesn't feel like you're very skilled when you take them down
and yeah just again the the density of it it's it's hard to it's hard to make it feel like a uh
a hand a hand-picked thing um when all this stuff is going on
the boss fights by comparison have this thing where yeah sometimes it's just
hit them with uh a specific weapon or hit them only in this body part uh you see that a lot but
I feel like that reward of um you know the cyclops right you know figure out that you have to not only
hit him in the eye but hit him with the sword specifically to do any damage you know the cyclops
is not an impossible enemy it's more about figuring out what you have to do to take them down that feels
more rewarding as a as a combat encounter than um these castlevania-like moments uh on the screen
which you know this game really isn't a platformer uh for the most part it's all uh there's not many
pitfalls other than in the caves and stuff like that I feel like the enemies aren't doing a good job
but the bosses redeem it because there's even ones like uh that siren uh where you have to first play
the harp to um to avoid being drawn in by her and then you can you could start attacking her uh little
things like that make the the boss fights feel plussed up even if their sprites aren't particularly
uh grand or uh their battles you know cue in like anything extra yeah like it's just a more focused
experience when you're fighting these instead of the again randomly placed enemies it definitely felt
like the boss fights were designed in a way where they were not like super hard technically like
they all only took a few hits to kill but but like you're saying the the fact that there's like this
other element that like is immersive in the world that you have to figure out and like it's it's some
technical gameplay thing you have to do makes like that feel like the interesting diff like challenge of
the boss fight rather than like can I hit it this many times before it hits me that many times
and there's a good variety of these boss fights too it's not uh I guess like it depends on what you
call a boss fight but like even that bull that guards uh the temple of zeus not a challenging thing
at all right like it it's just a unique sprite that happens to uh rev up first telling you that it's
going to start charging at you then it charges at you and if you time your hit right he just gets like a
little knock back and then charges you again like he's a stubborn bull you know he's not supposed to
be something you know an unprepared player could die from him right but for the most part it's just
supposed to be a teachable moment there's a lot of those kinds of enemies uh in this game that are
just one-off fights yeah and that that adds to the world building too and I think actually most of
those enemies I found easier than regular enemies but it was cool because it was like oh this is the
spot where the bull guards right right I think that's what I'm trying to get at too is that this
game is at its best when it's uh when it's doing that job of telling the story through gameplay it
never I think other than like when you run into um the whatever you name the princess when you run
into her that's when it like finally skips to cut scene other than that all the game uh story is told
in gameplay and so I feel like it it's at its best when it continues to do that not when it relies on
the npcs to tell you go get this and things will change
joe did you beat the game I didn't beat the game I think I got to maybe like the second to last
thing I got I think I was not in tartarus or hades which I assume is where you end um
what was it like the thea or whatever maybe that was last one or or the one across but yeah I was in
like the second to last dungeon where there's like I assume it's the second to last where there's like
layers of the dungeon you can go like through these different doors um like back into the background or
come out into the foreground right right maybe that was tartarus I can't remember it might have been
it might have been yeah uh I only asked because I didn't get to the end either but uh my understanding
is is that the the shadow fight in this game is significantly easier than the zelda 2 shadow fight
which uh some consider to be you know one of the hardest boss fights in a nes game that is otherwise
beatable you know uh we have nes hard games but then there's games that like you know nintendo makes
like that just throw you a bone every now and again and and uh this game I feel like yeah it's
it's a it's on the longer side and it does require a guide uh in my opinion sean I applaud you for trying
it without it but I think with a guide and with some time uh this is a beatable game and and that also
like deserves some acknowledgement too because some of these nes games just reach a point where they
you know they get too hard or they um they throw so many enemies at you that you're not supposed to
like you know maybe like through luck you'll get through eventually this game never really relies on
on any sense of luck or bad rng uh this is a game that's mostly about the adventure yeah and even like
obviously I wasn't I didn't beat this game either but even looking at the the boss fight it like it's
more so just a uh a little gimmick where you have to look at the upside down version of your fight
instead of where you're actually standing but it's still like that would be a memorable moment for me
if I if I played this when it came out like wow that was so cool I had to like learn that I was playing
uh that I had to look at the water like isn't that fun yeah it's like you see I'm just watching it now
too for the first time but you see your character and then his shadow is below you and then there's
like shadow and a shadow enemy that's also below you so like yeah it's like a mirror mirror image of
the fight I'm not sure why it just kind of looks like a a ninja like is is Hades a ninja but
maybe in this version of greek mythology right where you're Orpheus that can't fit on in your name
you have to spell it differently in order to fit it and if you look at like a walkthrough
for the battle of olympus uh one on mike's rpg center I am not related to this mike uh on the
walkthrough they just do it in bullet points and they make the game seem so basic and simple
the way that they describe it because this isn't like a game faq thing where it's all like nicely
formatted and everything this is just bullet points with text but just to read off like the very
the first four bullet points from arcadia make your way across arcadia until you reach the white
building and enter on the other side of the passage you'll have to fight the bull hit it four times on
the head when it charges at you to kill it continue on and enter zeus's palace kneel before him and
speak to him now the other gods will help you in your quest speak to him or any of the other gods at
any time to receive your password return to the main area of arcadia and enter the lower door in the
building to the west to reach attica it's like that that makes it seem like pretty dry uh you know
but that that's the difference between the actual gameplay experience of playing battle of olympus
and like talking about it now right like talking about the plot points here it's not the same you
know it's the same thing with like how the story didn't quite add up to what the uh to what the
gameplay was giving us i think i think they created a larger game than they uh than they could describe
yeah i i mean i also think that the way that that is written like because like this game is big enough
that you can get lost there is a need for a like sort of step-by-step process like that but in games
that are just as uh in games that engage you just as much like doom would just be like get to end
kill everything and then the next level would be get to end kill everything flip switch kill the rest
like it doesn't need to be a full paragraph i think a lot of game faqs uh walkthroughs go into a little
bit too much detail so i kind of like this laconic version i do too but the issue that i
not the issue but like the thing about using the guide for me with this game was i mean i used a
guide for zelda 2 and for fax and i do and i and i had a great time with it that way but those games i
felt so much more like i could look at the guide and say what do i do next and it's like okay next i
have to get this thing put the guide down and then spend 20 minutes doing that thing where it's like
even if i don't read exactly what to do beat for beat um i can i can stick with the
you know i know i know my goal and i can the game can help me figure that out with this i didn't feel
like i had that option as much like i felt like i really needed to know beat for beat what to do
next so like it did sort of devolve at some points into like just for my experience because i was using
a guide into like a very like surgical experience where i'm like okay go through this door okay wait
before i do anything else because i'll get lost look back at the guide okay next what do i do like
i felt that specifically in the yeah in in the forest which was like what convinced me that i
just don't like this form of navigation but i i know what you're feeling yeah yeah because i just
i mean obviously i'm like comparing it now to these other games that were similar
and i didn't have that experience so much with those games so like it it felt a little disappointing
on that side for me and the story does miss every now and again too it's not um you know they're
trying to tell it all through gameplay but it's not necessarily always successful i didn't find out
until uh looking at one of the guides that before you approach the final boss with hades there's a
room just uh one door leading to another and there's like a statue in the middle of the room and
you're just supposed to know that that's your uh that that's your like princess that you're trying
to rescue but she's been turned to stone by hades it's like it's not it's never pointed out it's not
like i don't know it's it's not like the most uh elegant way to describe that kind of situation like
it would have been cool if we would have seen hades like other form and him casting that spell on
her like first we thought we rescued her successfully got to the end and then it's like oh nope here's
this gotcha but instead you just walk into the room she's already a statue there's no
interaction there's no pause also isn't that supposed to be a thing like i don't i don't
quite remember who is it orfus no no like you the dude goes into haiti or goes into tartarus and talks
to hades and is like yeah you can take her but you can't this is persephone i think i don't know
but you can't look back behind you to see if she's still following you and then he's like
he does and then she turns to stone or something like that maybe i'm mixing up my mythology but it
just felt wrongly applied
i was trying to find out the answer for you shawma instead i got a much more interesting question on
google can medusa turn hades to stone and i i you know that's like just an interesting question the
answer is apparently not because medusa did not have the power to turn gods to stone uh that wasn't
um that wasn't on the back of the box of the medusa right right
on the sequels and spinoff side uh we have a game boy version of the battle of olympus
released much later in 1993 and if you're starting to ask yourself wait a minute i had a game boy i
had a lot of games on the game boy why didn't i get uh battle of olympus on game boy it's because it
was actually only released in europe so this is a very uh you know series of strange events but it must
have been that a european developer specifically ported the game over to game boy and then nintendo
or whoever was just like cool release it uh but don't bother translating it or doing whatever i
mean like surely it's in english right if it's for the uk or something maybe it's just in greek
yeah maybe it was just for greek audiences interestingly enough though it's pretty much
the same game it's not worth pointing out what the differences are they pretty much ported
the nes game over to you know the game boy has that weird thing where uh sprites are slightly
bigger so it you know in order to communicate detail so there's a lot of scrolling going on and
a lot of like uh unanticipated collisions yeah uh so you know this game this version isn't perfect
but nevertheless there was a way to play battle of olympus on the go well i think we have to go
i knew that was what you were gonna do i have to go to the bathroom wait wait sean sean before you go
to the bathroom all right there is one other thing we have to do oh and that is yeah that the essential
games list sean you first yeah i've got pretty mixed feelings about this game i i did enjoy playing it
uh but a lot of the same frustrations that i felt in other similar games are still here and one of
those is just like these open world uh 2d scrollers where it's not all on the same plane this is a very
specific gripe that i have and where you go in like into the back of the game and you're supposed to
sort of like have your heading or just use a guide i can't do that i can't navigate games like this
and that's that's a huge reason uh why i i am up two minds on this game the other being that
like we've described like the combat and enemies are kind of haphazard in my opinion
uh i do think it's one of the more the more clearly described like how do i get to from point
to point b in terms of like what you're supposed to do maybe not how you're supposed to get there
um in terms of the npcs and uh the environment but i'm gonna have to just like settle for a play it
here and not recommend this be on the essential games list uh it's it's totally like above average
all right that's what we'd love to hear you might think i'm gonna go to joe next but i've thought
about it and i've been going to joe second for a really long time and i'd like to go second so joe
you're gonna finish this off today you you you've earned it thank you thank you i've earned second
yeah i think the battle of olympus is a great adventure game filled with mostly like the vague
idea of fetch quests you know that's making it sound very boring but it is really just like go
get this thing and then go get that thing there's no like we didn't talk about olives right right the
olives that you need to um go ahead and purchase like you know get 50 of these and i'll give you a
a very uh an item you need uh you know that's not even my problem and fetch quest is being mean
here i guess what i'm saying is like there wasn't the the triforce element right where it's like oh
defeat these people to get this thing that will bring you to the boss it didn't it didn't quite
have that it was mostly like get this thing then get that thing there's some moderate i guess puzzle
solving on on at least like it without a guide uh there's some of that going on that's all like
that's all like good things in my opinion i actually feel like the combat is the thing that keeps
the battle of olympus off the essential games list for me and not just because the enemies were
difficult it's not about their difficulty um even though maybe that's what i made it sound like i
think it's just that that's a very monotonous thing that happens all the time uh when you're not like
actually exploring and trying to figure out what to do next on your grand quest you're just dealing
with these enemies over and over and over again it just doesn't make for a very interesting game
so um it's not on my essential games list vote and i'm not going to vote for it uh but on a more
interesting note this game made me kind of want to revisit zelda 2 because i have a feeling that the
combat is much better in zelda 2 and zelda 2 was kind of doing the same thing adventure wise that
battle of olympus was doing so maybe that could push it over the edge and finally onto the essential
games list but we need everybody else to agree as well joe every single one of you forget about
yeah forget about zelda 2 forget that i even mentioned it because i know you're gonna say
essential we're talking about the battle of olympus what is your vote for that game so i'm a sucker for
this kind of game i i think that like this format um just does a really good job of giving you that
feeling of going on an adventure uh so i really really like this game a lot and if it seems like
in the episode i had a lot to say that was negative about it that's because throughout the episode i have
been trying to justify why i am also not going to vote at essential and that's because most of what i've
already said but like the the major thing that i couldn't put my finger on about what i wasn't enjoying
about this game as much as those other games is if i'm pressed to come up with the answer is that
attacking element where i start to feel like i got kind of bored of it because it wasn't giving me the
like challenge isn't the right word but like it wasn't giving my my like brain the challenge that i
want to wear like i gotta like have a little bit of thought put into like when i attack and not just
attack attack attack i mean granted there are times where something swoops down at you you gotta
time it right but it just got tedious to me for that that combined with like the the element that
feels like a maze in which i need to really be looking back and forth between the guide and the
game over and over again keeps it from the level of faxanadu or zelda 2 which i which i love so much
so i also sometimes have a tough time like remembering that i don't have to decide if
something is either essential or horrible i think this is a fantastic game and i think it's definitely
a play it it's just not quite up to the standard of those other games that i think are better
i like that that's a good point especially with people who have gripes about some things that are
and are not on the essential games list uh there is a whole like play it section that just isn't
interesting right like we're not trying to make a play it list you can decide what uh you want to
play and stuff like that we do keep that on the website yeah we'll still tell you yeah we have that
if you're interested yeah if you want to live your life being told what to do by three guys like you
know i guess we could put in like other columns too for just other random information could have a
wheel that just spins every game we've covered so far and whatever it lands on that's what you have
to play that day or that week or that whole year wow uh we could do that instead what we're going to
do is we're going to keep recording episodes of nostalgia next week we have the uh spiritual
successor to the battle of olympus championship bowling thank you thank you for the for the one
laugh sean i agree sensible chuckle it's a very sensible chuckle a bowling ball is like an olive
yeah of course bowling it was probably yeah homer from the simpsons loves to bowl and homer wrote the
odyssey that's true wow and if you if you only root for teams in your city you're a homer there you go
now um if you if championship bowling is like yeah i'll take it or leave it you know i i could use
better games why don't you check out our other um uh podcast nostalgia bites which is exclusive to our
patreon patreon.com slash nostalgia to join and we are doing the portopia serial murder case which is a
a game that only was ever released in japan but got a fun english translation and is kind of like
one of the first text-based adventure games ever in japan uh that i think came out first on computers
but then eventually on famicom so it has again a non-linear storytelling with detective elements
and you can interrogate people and you can pick up evidence and you can take notes and ask people
questions and visit locations uh you go into a building with a toilet can you flush the toilet
you can use a payphone all right well we'll we'll see i'll play it okay yeah i think you'll have to
for the episode uh because the the patrons you know that's what that's we're giving them what
they pay for that's true they do pay for this yeah we lock champ we lock a portopia serial murder case
because it's a good game we lock that behind nostalgia bites but if you want the free content
we'll keep making episodes like championship bowling yeah that's how this whole podcast works
we decide for you know arbitrarily what nintendo releases in chronological order and then just uh
put that on the free feed you